[Music]
hello i'm here to talk to you about a
feature that i've wanted on the web for
years now something that has been tried
many times before but this time
this time it feels like we're really
close
i am of course talking about page
transitions
you know what i mean right this kind of
thing
i look at this in the material design
guides and
it just looks really good
not only that it gives the user context
to the navigation it's clear which
information is coming from where
and the direction of travel
whereas on the web
click pop that's your lot
why can't we have nice things well one
reason is that page transitions involve
parts of the old thing and new thing
animating together in perfect harmony
but on the web when you navigate the old
document goes away and the new one
arrives and there's no opportunity for
the two to work together
but that's only true with traditional
web navigations with single page apps
you're driving the state change yourself
so
you can do what you want
so why don't we see lots of sites doing
cool transitions between pages
there isn't exactly a shortage of single
page apps out there
well the truth is it's really hard with
the apis we have today
even something like a simple fade is
hard
how would you keep both states alive for
the duration of the transition it's not
particularly easy in modern frameworks
there's also lots of subtle
accessibility and usability pitfalls
if you're going from a scroll page to a
page back up at the top how do you
handle that
if either of the states contain a video
or an iframe how do you avoid their
state's resetting as you juggle the dom
around
what if you wanted to create a
transition where this element in a
scrollable container moves over to the
other container
well that didn't work thanks to overflow
hidden
to fix this you'll need to temporarily
pop the item out to the root of the page
which often means changing how you've
structured your css like i'm not saying
it's impossible
but it's not easy
meanwhile folks over on android and ios
have dedicated apis to make this kind of
thing a breeze and
oh that's just not fair i want some of
that so we've been experimenting with an
api to level the playing field and parts
of it are behind a flag in canary
already
in fact all the demos i'm going to show
you are running in the browser so i hope
by the end of this video you'll be as
excited about this feature as i am
we're going to take this basic site and
use the new api to transition between
states it's a single page app because
that's what the experimental stuff in
canary supports right now but don't
worry
this whole system is designed to work in
a very similar way for multi-page apps
we just
haven't implemented it yet
here's a rough example of how
navigations are currently handled
let's add some transitions
first up we're going to add a fallback
for browsers that don't support this new
api so things continue to work as normal
otherwise i'm going to create a
transition and start it letting the api
know when the dom change is complete
some of the api names here may change
like we might rename some stuff but the
pattern should remain the same
the important part is the api gets to
see the state of things before and after
the dom change
and just like that
we've got this nice subtle fade between
states
okay
fading isn't really interesting so let's
do something better
but to do that we need to understand how
this fading thing actually
worked
first up the browser took essentially a
screenshot of the page and it held it in
place while we changed the dom
underneath
then it created a dom structure like
this out pseudo-elements containing both
the screenshot of the previous state and
a live representation of the current
state also as a flattened image
this element structure sits over the top
of everything hiding the real dom
underneath
the outgoing image fades from one to
zero and the incoming image fades from
zero to one
and that's your crossfade
once it's done
it goes away seamlessly revealing the
real page underneath
but
like all my favorite apis this is mostly
built of existing platform features and
you can mess around with them for
instance
each of these elements can be targeted
using css pseudoelement selectors and
all of the animations are driven by css
so we can change what they do with css
like i said the outgoing and incoming
images crossfade so
let's just set a longer animation
duration
and the result of that
it's a super slow crossfade
alright fair enough but let's do more
let's change that animation completely
first let's define some keyframes
this slides the element out to the left
and this slides the element in from the
right now let's use those keyframes
we'll slide the outgoing image to the
left
and the incoming image in from the right
just using normal css animations
and the result of that
not bad
there are a couple of things that could
do better of course firstly it's always
sliding in the same direction even when
going back to the thumbnails view ah
we'll fix that later
the other thing is well the header it
slides out only to slide back in again
you can see that along the top
ideally it wouldn't move at all since
it's pretty consistent between the two
states
well the page transition api lets us do
that
we assign a page transition tag to the
header using css
site header here that's just an
identifier you can pick whatever name
you want
we also give it paint containment which
is just a requirement for this api
this changes how the page is captured
previously the page was being captured
as a single screenshot but when you give
an element a page transition tag it's
captured separately but still just as a
screenshot
so now we have incoming and outgoing
images for the root
and
separate incoming and outgoing images
for the header
in the same way we got one of these
structures for the root of the page we
get another of these structures
representing the header
it's now something we can target with
css using the page transition tag we
assigned it which is site header in this
case
that means we can animate it
independently of the rest of the page
here's how it looks now
we haven't told the header how to
animate so it's just doing the default
thing which is to crossfade and that
might looks pretty good
but we can do even better with one small
change
see where it says http 203 in the header
there well
let's capture that separately too
so now we have three parts transitioning
independently the route the header and
the text in the header i already
mentioned that the default transition is
a crossfade but you know i sneakily left
one detail out it also transitions the
size and position of the element from
its before state to its after state
and that didn't matter for the route or
the header because those are in the same
place and size before and after the dom
change but for our heading text it does
this really satisfying shift across to
make space for the back button
i really like how we're making small
additions and adjustments to create a
transition that's super tailored to this
site
also
those three parts that form our
transition the title the header and the
root they have a flat structure even
though in our real dom the site title is
in the site header and the header is
somewhere within the root
they're treated as siblings during the
transition and that's a good thing
remember this example from earlier doing
simple dom transitions is hard because
of the nesting
but with the flat structure of page
transitions
it's not a problem
okay so things are looking pretty good
here but what about on desktop
it feels
i don't know
a bit much like the whole page sliding
across seems
a bit over the top makes you feel a bit
nauseous a bit dizzy but we can solve
this the usual way we solve things when
it comes to responsive design
here's the transition styles for the
route and here are the overrides for
desktop just using regular media queries
the main difference is they use a
different set of keyframes
that means we can keep our previous
transitions on mobile where the whole
thing slides from the side but over on
desktop we can have something a bit more
subtle like this fade and slide i don't
know i just made this up i'm not a
designer you could probably think of
something better
but while we're being responsive
here's the code from earlier that
triggers the transition
currently the transition is skipped if
the browser doesn't support the api but
let's also add a check for prefers
reduce motion
i mean alternatively you could keep the
transitions but just make them really
subtle for users that prefer less motion
remember it prefers reduced motion not
prefers no motion but i'm just going to
avoid them completely you know be a bit
lazy whatever
all right what else can we do
well watch this
i'm going to take that large video in
bed there and i'm going to make it its
own layer in the transition
but this video embed only exists on this
page it doesn't exist in this page the
thumbnails page
but that's that's fine like you can
create transition layers that only have
an outgoing or an incoming component
it's a pretty common thing to do like
you know as things appear or as things
disappear but that's not what we're
going to do here
here's the rough code for when one of
those thumbnails is clicked
using inline styles we can say
treat this as the video embed
it isn't actually the video embed it's
just the thumbnail but for the sake of
the transition we're saying that the
thumbnail is the before state of the
real video embed
and the effect of that
you ready
the thumbnail now grows into the main
embed it doesn't matter that there were
different elements in the dom we told
the page transition api to treat them as
the same thing so that's exactly what it
did
and what you saw there was just a
default transition that moves from the
before position in size to the final
position and size while crossfading the
images
but we can go even further here's an
even more developed example
i've made some tweaks to the easings
i've made the video description part of
the transition i've made the sidebar
part of the transition as well and that
stays fixed in some navigation cases
maybe this is too much like i said i'm
not a designer i'm just playing around
with new toys like maybe you can do
better so
give it a go this is all running in
chrome canary using the page transition
api today
i'm really excited about this feature
because well it's got reasonable
defaults but with little bits of css and
javascript you can make the transition
as custom as you want and really
in many ways
that's thanks to you lot
no seriously we released a different
version of this api last year it didn't
use css animations and transitions were
restricted to like a few presets
feedback from developers made it clear
presets weren't enough it needed to be
customizable
couldn't agree more
and that's what drove the second version
of this api that's what gave us the
ability to do this
all right one last thing before i
totally outstay my welcome in this final
version the transition when pressing the
back button slides from the left as
you'd expect you know when going forward
slide from the right when going back
slide from the left
so how do you make the transition
different depending on that
we're actually working on higher level
ways to make this easier but in the
meantime a useful way to influence the
type of transition is to add a temporary
class to the html element
once you've done this you can use the
presence of that class to make
adjustments to the transition
but how do you know when to add that
class
it's something you can totally do with
the history api that's been in browsers
for ages but
it's not a good api it's really messy
however we're working on a new api that
aims to make it easy and that's the
navigation api it's a totally separate
thing to the page transitions api but
they play well together
for instance
the navigation event here fires when a
navigation or traversal happens and you
can hook into this to override the
default navigation
it can act as a router for single page
apps and more like there's loads it can
do that i just don't have time to go
into today
but one thing it makes easy is detecting
whether the navigation is forwards or
back and that's what this code example
is doing
this makes it easy to add the right
class name to control the transition and
it's also what i used in the final
version of this demo
links to the demo but also explainers
docs specs they're all in the
description including a code lab where
you can learn even more about the api
so i guess all that is left for me to
say is
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you